[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELISSA MONAHAN: Welcome
to our first wellness day.
We've never had a
wellness day here,
so we've got the vendor fair out
in the courtyard y'all probably
got to check out.
We've got this talk.
So really happy
that you're here.
This panel is the intersection
of wellness and technology.
So we've got a bunch of experts
here to talk to us about it.
We're a tech company.
We're very concerned
about that intersection.
As you know, Google is a
leader in workplace health
and wellness.
We have our GFit program.
We've nutrition.
We have massage therapy.
But we also recognize that
we have a lot to learn.
So that is why we have
these folks here today.
I'm going to introduce them.
And then we'll ask
some questions.
We'll leave time for audience
questions at the end.
This is also being filmed, so
it'll be on our YouTube channel
in a few weeks, and y'all can
post it and watch it then.
Yeah, so let's get started.
So first I'm going to
try to get all the names
right, the pronunciation.
So Andy Petranek.
ANDY PETRANEK: You got it
MELISSA MONAHAN: Did I nail it?
ANDY PETRANEK: Yeah.
MELISSA MONAHAN: So
Andy's the founder
of CrossFit LA and the
Whole Life Challenge,
which is really amazing.
My husband and I
did it, and I highly
recommend everyone do it.
It's life changing.
Then we've got Dice Iida-Klein.
Dice is a yoga instructor at
Yoga Glow and, if I might say,
a world-class handstand master.
I've been taking his
videos for years,
and I'm a really big fan.
Y'all have got to check him out.
Your mind will be blown.
Kim Whitman, who's the
founder and executive producer
of "Yoga Today," it's
a beautiful sight
of yoga classes
filmed in nature.
And so everyone should
definitely check that out.
Jeff Egler is the MD and medical
director at Parsley Health.
This is a really
cool company, it's
redefining medical
care with a root cause,
whole-person approach and
focus on data technology
and real doctor-patient
relationships,
which we all want
and appreciate.
And then lastly, Tom Freeman
is the learning and development
manager at Headspace.
Headspace is out
in the courtyard.
You're probably also familiar
with it, meditation app.
I can personally attest to
the effectiveness of that app.
It's really great.
And Googlers get a
really good discount.
So check it out.
Putting in a plug for all y'all.
So let's get started.
I'm going to just
ask some questions.
We'll go down the line and then
leave time for y'all to ask
questions as well.
So just briefly, we'll
just go down the line,
starting with Andy.
Tell us briefly what led you
into the wellness profession?
What factors motivated you to
get to where you are today?
ANDY PETRANEK: It's an
interesting question.
We were talking about
my varied background.
So I got to go kind of quick
because it's very varied.
I was kind of forced into it.
I was a Marine back
in the early '90s.
And I had to get in shape
to be in the Marines.
And I didn't really
realize at the time,
but it was my first introduction
to being a fitness coach.
I was responsible for a
platoon of men going to war
and had to make sure that
they were fit and ready to go.
And lo and behold, that
became my profession.
Four years after leaving the
Marines, I started racing.
I started doing professional
adventure racing sponsored
by Red Bull.
It's like triathlon meets, I
don't know, extreme sports.
We would rock climb and
kayak and mountain bike
and 300, 400, 500-mile races.
And people started
to ask me what
I was doing to be in shape.
And I would tell
them what I did.
And then they would say, well,
can you write a program for me?
Or can you train me?
And that's how I got
my first clients,
and I became a fitness coach.
And I started going down
the road of more holistic.
I worked with Paul Chek at the
Chek Institute in San Diego.
And I started to
go down the road
toward being a wellness and
corrective exercise specialist.
And then I discovered CrossFit.
And it kind of changed the
context of my training,
because I started having so
much fun with workouts again
and training again.
I opened up CrossFit
Los Angeles,
which was one of the first
10 CrossFit in the world.
And was really responsible in
the beginning of that movement
for delivering a lot of the
publicity for the movement,
for CrossFit around
the world, even though,
I just owned a little
gym in Santa Monica.
And the whole of challenge came
out of my desire as a coach
to affect what choices people
made in their everyday life
outside the gym.
Because they could come see me
two, three, four times a week
at the gym, but
what would they do
when they weren't at the gym?
And that was really
the mother lode for me.
And my business partner,
Michael Stanwick, he and I
are co-founders
of the Challenge,
he was my head coach CFLA.
And we were searching
for this answer,
and we knew it was
not just in exercise.
So we built this
Whole Life Challenge
around a holistic approach,
which is food and stretching
and mobility and clarity of
mind, gratitude, reflection
on how you're doing.
And we put it together in a
way that builds community.
So we kind of tumbled
upon this format
and grew it from 150
in the first challenge
to we had 23,000
people around the world
do the one in January, which is
always our biggest of the year.
So that's really it, yeah.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Dice.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: So
the question is, is me
venturing into the health
and wellness industry?
Or how did I get it?
Let me just say I
think early on, being
a kid I realized the
direct correlation
between physical fitness,
or at least moving my body,
and how that helped more my
mental state or the ability
to almost relax or calm down.
I played a lot of sports
throughout my younger years,
all the way through high school.
And in college I
was a big gym rat.
But I'd never really
touched upon yoga,
but I started working for a
little company called Lululemon
at one point.
And at the time, they
allowed their employees
to take any sort of
physical fitness,
go into the physical
fitness world.
As long as you
wore their apparel,
you could take the
class for free.
So I ventured into
so many things
I never thought I would touch.
And this was right after
I'd graduated from UCLA.
And I basically
tried a yoga class.
And, yeah, I fell
in love with yoga.
And I never really
thought I would be
able to share it or teach it.
That wasn't really the idea.
But I did realize that there
was this strong connection
between mind-body, and how I
was always so physically active,
but I realized I needed to be
physically active to, I think,
be able to handle
what's going on up here.
And I think that goes for
most human beings, in general.
And once you start to
realize that connection,
things start to go
in a good direction.
But the ability
to actually share
what I'm able to
practice and teach really
came from the company
that I'm fortunate enough
to work for, Yoga Glow.
They are really
bringing, I think,
yoga to the masses in
a way that some people
that are in remote
areas or can't really
get to a public yoga class,
we're able to reach out to them
or at least be with
them in their home
and provide some
sort of clarity,
serenity, all the things that
I think we're all looking for.
So I don't know.
I guess I would say I just
stumbled into the health
and wellness realm.
I didn't really intend upon.
It wasn't something that I
was so keen on getting to.
But I feel very
fortunate and blessed
to be able to actually be a part
of it in some tiny little way,
so that's it in
a nutshell, yeah.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Kim.
KIM WHITMAN: Thank you.
And like Dice, I also am
someone who's stumbled into--
actually fell.
I crashed on my
skis in Argentina,
had this horrible
injury that I was
recovering for seven months.
I crushed my leg, had
all these surgeries.
And so, yeah, I, like
many people who find yoga,
it's because of an injury.
You never seek
health and wellness
until you don't
have it, which is
something Parsley knows about.
So anyways, yeah,
so, I came back.
And I was in Jackson
Hole being sort
of a ski bum for a couple
of years after grad school,
I actually did
study engineering,
which is not what--
so I now I say
I'm in the business of renewable
energy, but in the human form.
So it's all come full circle.
But, yeah, so anyways,
I was recovering
from this ski accident.
And I was doing a ton of yoga.
I'd always done tons of sports
in college and high school.
I was an athlete, skier,
lacrosse, swimmer, rower.
And I've never been
in better shape
than when I was doing 8
to 10 yoga classes a week.
I can say that fully.
And I've been in the gym, in the
weight room, and all of this.
So I was just floored by
not just the physical,
but also the mental
conditioning that you
get from the practice of yoga.
And then it goes into the
Whole Life Challenge thing.
Like, you're in this
vein of wellness.
And all of a sudden,
you're starting
to make better decisions about
what you eat because you don't
want to have a
hamburger in your belly
when you're in yoga
class doing a handstand.
And then all of a sudden,
you're speaking a little kinder
to people, and you're making
better choices in terms
of every life decision.
So yoga's one of
those things that
just permeates your whole life.
And all of a sudden,
you're in it.
Like, you don't even mean to.
It's like a sneaky
form of exercise.
Like you don't mean to--
you don't know.
You're thinking, oh,
I'm going to go stretch.
And, like, oh, you kind
of get your butt kicked.
So, yeah, I am also extremely
grateful for falling
into yoga, quite literally, and
the path that it's taken us on.
We started the yoga
show as a content
carrot for a larger investment
for a different company
altogether.
And then so many
people were loving it.
We spun it out into
its own business.
It was like on the top 10
podcasts in iTunes in 2006,
up there with-- people were
consuming it ravenously,
writing in saying, like
what are you doing?
You're putting an hour yoga show
filmed in nature in HD online,
and you're giving
it away for free?
Like this is too
good to be true.
And of course, it was.
And so people were
consuming it ravenously.
They were like, well, we
don't want to miss one.
I'm doing yoga every day
now because of this show.
And like, what's going on?
I'm losing all
this weight, or I'm
getting over this depression.
So the letters that
were pouring in
were so moving that we
couldn't turn it off
when the larger investment that
we made it for was turned off.
And so we spun it,
did the freemium thing
before Pandora went
to Pandora One,
and we didn't know
if anyone was going
to pay for content online.
So it's been this like complete
evolution from the wild,
because we're in Jackson Hole.
So we're doing it all
from a media vacuum,
which has been interesting.
But, yeah, no, it's been a
wild ride during this time,
when the internet's sort
of taking over television,
to stumble into
it as an outsider.
I feel really blessed.
But most of all to stumble
into yoga as an outsider
and now be an insider
and, like, realize
it's changed my whole life and
be so grateful for the people
that it's put me
in contact with.
So, yeah, that's
how it happened.
It's pretty wild.
Thank you.
JEFFREY EGLER: My
name's Jeff Egler.
I'm the medical director
of Parsley Health
here in Los Angeles.
Thank you for having us here.
This is a lot of fun.
It's great to come out and
talk about what we're doing
and to share it with people.
I think I have an
interesting answer for you,
interesting in that I feel like
even as a physician, trained
in a allopathic
conventional manner, an MD,
I also stumbled into
health and wellness
after practicing medicine
for more than a decade.
And what I mean by that is I
think you've all heard this.
I think it's probably
becoming a bit of a cliche.
But my opinion, and
I'm not alone here,
is that we don't
really have a disease--
we don't really have a health
care system in our country.
We have more of a
disease management
system in our country.
And quite frankly, it
doesn't really even do
a good job of managing disease.
And so I had been
practicing as a physician.
Initially, I chose
to be a physician
because I started
in engineering,
which is something that many of
you might be able to relate to.
And I really loved the
science and the math.
And as I started to
study more of this,
I started to realize that the
application that I wanted to
was in the human form.
I wanted to solve
problems with people.
So I went into
medicine, and that's
where I spent my attention
for the first decade or so,
which is finding disease
and trying to fix that,
rather than focusing
on health and wellness.
And so quite honestly, I
can say looking back now,
it's very ironic that I
wasn't trained really,
nor did I really think in terms
of keeping people healthy.
I was looking for
disease and then
trying to get them
back to health.
But really that
horse was already
sort of out of the barn.
So moving into what we
do now at Parsley Health,
you may be familiar
with some of the terms
functional medicine,
integrative medicine, holistic.
We don't necessarily attach
or identify ourselves
in any of those one ways.
But that is the line
that we're taking.
And the reason we
don't attach to it
is because we really feel like
we take the best of everything.
We have the science
training to look out there
amongst all the different health
modalities and really take
the best and incorporate
them in a personalized
way for the individual.
And I got to that
by really realizing
after a decade of
medicine I wasn't taking
really good care of myself.
And I was teaching at USC.
I was teaching
doctors to be doctors.
And as I started to take
better care of myself,
I started asking more questions
about what I was eating
and how I was sleeping
and, of course,
reducing stress and exercising.
And as I started
to translate that
into teaching my
physicians-in-training
to do that with
their patients, they
were looking at me like
deer in the headlight.
You know I don't have time
to talk to them about that.
I just need to
diagnose, prescribe,
get to the next room.
And so I realized that I didn't
fit into that model anymore.
And luckily, at that time,
Parsley Health was coming up.
And now I get to practice
medicine and health
in the way that fits
for me a lot better.
Thanks.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Tom.
TOM FREEMAN: Cool.
Thanks very much for having us.
So, yeah, I think
my story, if there's
one thing which kind of
pulls it all together,
I think it's the idea of
demystifying something.
So probably starting back in
my school days, university,
you guys say school, I had
this real passion to kind study
business psychology, so the
psychology of organizations
and how they work.
But at the same
time, I was rooted
in this idea of training and
people with like numbers,
and that didn't
really interest me.
But this huge idea of wellness
and getting more for yourself,
where I came across
that quite a lot.
This idea of mindfulness,
which doesn't have
to be this religious thing.
It can be this practical
thing which anyone can do,
that kind of was getting quite
a lot of traction around then
in literature, and loads and
loads papers coming about it.
At the same time, I was
like super stressed out.
Exam season was coming along.
You guys call them finals.
You probably relate to it's
a pretty stressful time.
So I went and saw
this therapist, part
of the university offering.
And he suggested I take up
meditation and give this thing
a try.
And I was amazed at how quickly,
how practical this thing was.
You can read a
book on it, and you
don't have to go off
to a monastery in Asia
and burn incense
and where robes.
It's something you can do in
your dorm room with friends.
And I think, like, wow, this
thing's really powerful.
This thing can turn
around your relationship
with stress,
anxiety, performance,
all that kind of stuff.
So that was that.
So I kind of finished
off my education,
did my master's,
started meditating.
And then I kind of
found Headspace.
And again, Headspace has
got this really interesting
mission.
I don't know.
People are probably
familiar with it.
But we have this mission
to demystify meditation.
Again, we have we have
our co-founder Andy, who
spent 10 years trying
to become a monk
and brought it back
to the rest in London
and had this clinic where he
would see people one on one
and teach them
mindfulness exercises.
And I came across
Headspace a few years ago
when we were quite
small back in London.
And like this mission
of demystifying
this thing, like with
work stuff at university
I was interested in,
like, demystifying
work, how it doesn't have to
be this thing where you're
tied to a desk for
eight hours a day.
You can do it anywhere you want.
Like looking at things
like employee well-being,
really, really important.
So that was kind of like the
demystifying of work piece.
But then Headspace came along.
It's like, whoa,
these guys are trying
to demystify this really,
really old thing which
is rooted in all of this
teaching and these trainings
and bringing it to like
a modern way of thinking,
a modern way of life.
So those two kind of
things came together.
And I joined Headspace back
in London a few years ago
when we were quite small.
And yeah, that for me, just
being part of that mission
was, yeah, just a huge
part of how I kind of--
well, my process, in particular,
how looking after the mind
and seeing it as this
everyday thing, which
doesn't have to be this
really religious thing,
I think that's a really
important way of looking at it.
So, yeah, that's kind of my
journey from education to work.
And it's funny
being here actually.
We used to be one block from
here, around the corner.
We used to walk past
this place all the time.
Had office envy, big time.
So, yeah, don't worry.
But, yeah, we moved a
couple of years ago.
But, yeah, that's my journey.
And now I'm kind of working
in learning development.
And before this, my role
was culture manager.
So in terms of the behaviors and
the culture of an organization,
how do you kind of build a place
which fits your brand, which
takes well-being
really seriously,
which encourages your
employees to meditate and take
good breaks and look
after their minds at work,
yeah, that's kind
of how I got here.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Awesome.
Thank y'all so much.
And I find it so
interesting that we often
think of health as physical.
And everyone's touching upon
the spiritual-psychological.
I mean, three of y'all
have psychology degrees,
so I think that's
very interesting.
So thank you so much.
Next question, so we are
talking about the intersection
of technology and wellness.
So we do want to dive into that.
So how have you seen technology
impact the wellness space
in a positive way?
And then on the opposite,
have you seen negative impacts
from technology on
the wellness field?
So we can just go right
back down the line.
ANDY PETRANEK: We wouldn't have
a business without technology.
We wouldn't have a
business without Facebook
or without Google or without--
the interaction of
community or the building
of community online has
been such a powerful tool.
The hard part, the interesting
part for us was how to do that
effectively so that you didn't--
so that it was a valuable
space to spend time in
and it wasn't just another
recreation of Facebook
or a place that
people already were.
So I'm forever indebted to
technology for my whole life.
I mean, I'm so grateful that
life has brought me here.
I can work out of the
comfort of my home
and communicate
with 20,000 people
at a time doing the
Whole Life Challenge,
and they can interact with me.
They can interact with the game.
They can score themselves.
They can do things that
wouldn't be allowed.
I think one of the challenges
for me around health
and mindfulness and
technology is this insatiable
need for people to think--
they think they need more data,
they need more information.
And I and I think that without
the consciousness-- like one
of the things that we don't do
and the Whole Life Challenge,
we don't partner-- we've
never partnered with Fitbit
or connected in an automatic
step tracker or habit tracker.
We want people to actually
have to do it manually.
We want people to be conscious.
We want people to be
aware of what they're
doing so that they're
actually making choices
about the way they
spend their time.
And they're aware of how
they spend their time.
If it's too automatic, it's
just easy to lose track of.
I've done it myself.
I mean, I've experimented
with every fitness
tracker known to man.
I actually love
fitness trackers.
But when I don't--
when I get all this
data, it takes time
to actually go in
and look at the data.
And then what did you look at?
And what's important?
And how do you not
get lost in that?
So really for Whole Life
Challenge, it's not anti data.
It's be aware of
what you're doing.
And if the data supports--
if it supports you to
have a goal of walking
15,000 steps in a day and it
gets you moving, fantastic.
Don't just shoot
for 15,000 steps
because that's what Fitbit
tells you what to do, so thanks.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: Technology
positives and possible rooms
for improvement, I guess--
room for improvement.
Working for Yoga Glow, I mean,
I touched upon it already
with just my brief intro,
but one of the positives
is it's really brought, I
think, just health and wellness
to the masses, or at least
to people that are looking
to improve upon themselves.
Yeah, think it's a wonderful
way also to create community.
Or kind of like
Andy was saying, was
being able to not
globalize, but being
able to connect with people
around the globe that
are doing maybe the
same things as you are,
thinking the same way as you.
And so I think
technology, in general,
is just helping us to bridge
the gap between people
that seem so far away.
It's really bringing a
global community together.
Negative aspects?
I don't want to say it's
necessarily negative,
but I think, as cliche
as it may sound,
the one thing that I think
you hear a lot in yoga
is this idea of being in the now
or being in the present moment.
And I feel like at
times with technology,
because you may have a Fitbit
tracker or something that's
tracking your steps
or you have a goal
that you're looking
for, you tend
to either weigh on the side
of the past or the future.
And you're always kind
of going back and forth
between the two, which is
normal, and it should happen.
That's how you can
assess a situation
and move forward or
make changes as needed.
But oftentimes we forget that--
again, it's cliche.
But everything you have,
everything you need
is right here right now.
And if you can sometimes
put the phone down or put
even Yoga Glow down
or whatever it may be,
you can realize that--
MELISSA MONAHAN: Don't say that.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: Yeah,
yeah, don't say that.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER] I think all I'm
saying is that sometimes--
ANDY PETRANEK: Qut
while you're ahead.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Technology can take
us out of the moment.
And then you start to realize
that a lot of times the most
important thing is to realize
that the things that you
do along the way to your goal,
those are what matter more.
That's kind of a
gift, the ability
to see how you
actually got somewhere
versus where you're trying
to go or even where you been.
But just being there now, yeah.
KIM WHITMAN: No.
And I agree with
everything you said,
and I don't want to repeat.
But that's exactly right.
It does take you
out of the moment.
I do think it's good in that
you're able to put your art
form, whether it's yoga
or whatever, CrossFit,
into the world and find
your people, lovely.
Love that.
I have people from
the Netherlands
that I'm friends with now that
I wouldn't be because of--
without yoga today,
or all over the world.
But, yeah, the drawback, and I
don't know if it's a drawback.
I think it's just we're in
a conversation right now.
This is not something black
and white, like good or bad.
We're in the gray right
now with how to manage--
I'm sure everyone saw Anderson
Cooper on "60 Minutes"
doing the cell phone tests.
He's hooked up.
And he's literally
giving off-- his brain
is giving off the same chemicals
that you get from cocaine
but checking his phone.
It's an addiction.
People are device addicted.
You get that little
hit of like dopamine
when you get a like
on your Instagram.
And Instagrams like
withholding likes so
that they come in in bulk now.
All these things, it's like
tech companies are intentionally
designing these things
to be addictive.
And as humans, it's like we
have to decide, OK, well--
and as creators of
technology, we have to decide,
well, let's have
that conversation.
And let's decide what
is in the best interest.
It's like the whole GMO debate.
It's like, yeah,
well, we can solve
vitamin A deficiencies
in populations
by inserting some
vitamin A in rice.
But then what are the cons--
it's like there's
good and there's bad.
And we're in the dialogue.
And I'm sure we'll look back
on this time as like, oh, wow,
this is the time that
they were scrambling
to figure it out culturally.
But I like to be an optimist
and think that technology really
does solve problems.
And in general, our lives
will be better for it.
So, yeah, I guess I'm
ambiguous on this.
But I agree with what you said.
JEFFREY EGLER: Agree with
most, if not all of it.
We've always had technology
from the beginning of man.
Fire is a technology.
And we will always have
technology to a certain degree.
And we are evolving
with our technology.
And it is really
interesting how quickly
we're evolving with our
technology, the differences
between generations,
that we actually
have to split generations
into different generations
because things are moving
and changing and adapting
so quickly.
As an example of
that technology,
I think that the
crisis that we've
started to see in terms
of obesity and diabetes
and heart disease and things
like that probably starting
around the '80s because
of the food industry,
which is a technology.
And certainly food industry made
things a lot more convenient
for us.
But at what cost?
And so I think that
through education we're
starting to reverse
some of those things.
So those are some of the things
that I think where technology--
and we're probably not
talking about the technology
that we're used to talking
about in this room.
But that's where I think some
of the negatives have been.
Positives, like Andy said, part
of what we do at Parsley Health
is in addition, of course,
to seeing patients,
we are able to communicate
with them through technology.
We actually don't
even have a phone line
because we do all of
our communications
through a secure portal where
patients can ask a question
and get an answer
within 24 hours.
And we have somebody
scanning it to make sure
if there's an emergency, that
gets addressed immediately.
We're a 21st-century
practice, where
I don't think a lot of doctors
are utilizing this fully.
But we can do telemedicine.
So it doesn't
really matter where
your office is located anymore.
I spoke with a patient
today who's in Florida.
So that technology
wasn't available.
We do blogs and offer
patients information
on a regular basis that way.
That wasn't available
to us 5, 10 years ago,
at least in the
way that it is now.
So that's all wonderful stuff,
and we integrate technology
into our decision-making
processes by having people--
we typically order
a lot more labs
that we use as biomarkers
because we have the technology.
Medicine has a tendency to lag
way behind other technologies.
And so in many ways, the
typical doctor out there
is probably way behind in
terms of the technology that's
available of diagnosing
problems, special tests.
And most doctors, and I say
this intelligently because
five years ago I
was most doctors.
And what I was teaching doctors
was not the cutting-edge stuff
that we're doing now.
But we have to learn how to
integrate that technology,
to understand it, and
explain it to people.
But we're utilizing
a lot of those things
now because we're also
looking at markers
that show what degree
of health you're in,
not just looking for--
the old way was sort of
looking at markers for disease.
And if you have this lab value,
then you have this disease.
But we can look at
more shades of gray
now and keep people in the
green rather than waiting
until the yellow or the red.
And just more
quickly, I would also
just add that I do have concerns
about technology, especially
our attachment to it.
And I think that this is
somewhat pseudo generational.
I'm a little bit older
than my wife, for example,
and we use our phones
completely different.
But there's only a five year,
seven year gap in there.
And the attachment
to texting, or I
can't have a moment
sometimes with my family
without having to
capture it in Instagram.
And that's concerning
to me because I
think I see so many people
that are out on a hike,
and they stop and
take a picture,
like I'll look at that later,
rather than actually taking
in the beauty in the moment.
So it is, again, back
to being present.
JEFFREY EGLER:
TOM FREEMAN: Thanks.
Yeah, I think this is a
really interesting one.
Headspace started as an events
company quite a few years ago.
So at first, we were
kind of like just
like this, just speakers.
And then we use
technology to really think
about how we could
scale our product.
And the vision of Headspace
is to improve the health
and happiness of the world.
And doing that through
the online means,
we found that to be
really, really powerful.
But also we're kind
of aware of this irony
of like offering guided
meditations through a phone.
It's a really common question.
Like, we get it from people.
And it comes in.
And, yeah, like, it's
a great question.
And we're aware of that irony.
But at the same time, like
it's being covered here,
it's all about that
relationship with your phone.
The iPhone in your
pocket, or Android,
is just a lump of glass and
metal and plastic, right?
But how you engage with that
product is entirely up to you
in your mind.
That's where it starts.
So that's kind of our
perspective on that.
And through
mindfulness, I think you
can learn to react and
engage with that product
in a different way.
So it's actually
quite interesting.
Every year, we do
a company retreat.
And for one day we take the team
away from the office for a day.
And part of that is
that everyone kind of
gives their phones to
me and to our team.
And in the morning you kind
of see these people thinking,
oh, I've been on my
phone for five years.
I haven't checked.
Hasn't been a day without
Instagram for three years.
And you see this reaction.
It's really, really interesting.
And for some people it's
really hard, and we get it.
But at the end of the
day, you're like, whoa.
We had one last week.
It was whole day.
It was like 12 hours
without a phone.
And by the end of
the day, you're like,
whoa, people-- well,
I thought people
were going to run to me saying,
can I have my phone back?
Can I have my phone back?
And like no one really ran to
me asking for their phone back.
People were like,
whoa, this is amazing.
I've had this whole
day where I haven't had
to take photos, upload things.
So I think, in a way,
like testing ourselves
to see if we can do that
is quite interesting,
even for a weekend
morning or something, just
going and putting
your phone away.
So there are positives
and negatives,
I think, in terms of
scaling something.
And if you have a phone
and you're on the go
and you want to train your
mind on on-the-go basis
without going off to a monastery
somewhere or putting robes on,
it's one way that
technology, I think,
can be really,
really beneficial.
And of course, you can
get addicted to it.
I'm guilty of
scrolling endlessly
through Instagram and stuff.
But at one point, you
do catch yourself.
You catch your mind
going, oh, this
is actually pretty useless.
This is pretty boring.
It's nice showing your
friends you care about them.
But it's not really showing
you care about your friends.
That's you just
ticking a picture.
So at some point--
I'm definitely not
an expert in this.
But through training and
looking how your mind works,
you can think actually this
isn't a great use of your time.
And that's you still engaging
with that bit of glass
and plastic, but like it's kind
of, yeah, it starts with you, I
think, a big part of that.
And also just to reference like
at-work piece, because fully
aware that as soon as
you come in the office,
you've got emails coming in.
You've got Slacks or
whatever going on.
And like, yeah,
it's just a big part
of kind of startup
life or business
life, whatever that is.
But I think companies can
start thinking about technology
in a different way.
And one of the things
we do at Headspace
is that we block out
no-meeting blocks in your days,
one at 10 o'clock
and one at 3 o'clock.
We have these blocks when
people don't have meetings.
But in those times,
people can go off
and meditate if they want to.
So they can kind of disengage
from technology if they want
and just sit and meditate
for 10, 15 minutes.
And we never force
it, of course,
but you can go outside, take
a walk around the block,
get some fresh air.
But I think also
companies really
encouraging their employees
to disengage with technology
and seeing kind of better breaks
and disengaging from technology
is actually a way of
being more productive
and engaging with technology
in a different way.
So there are a few different
levels to it there probably.
But it does ultimately start,
I think, yeah, with your mind.
MELISSA MONAHAN:
That is so awesome.
I think we should start
thinking about that at Google.
It's a really good idea.
Just as a personal anecdote to
a couple of things y'all said,
with Whole Life Challenge I can
say that there was a week where
you could only check
social media once a day.
And it was hard.
We had to turn notifications
off our phones.
It's hard.
Yeah, I think
that's part of it is
if you want to move towards
a lifestyle like that, where
you're only checking
it that way,
you got to get the
notifications off.
Otherwise you're like,
oh, someone liked it.
Oh, my god, look.
And then on the
positive, I wanted
to say just an interesting
story is that years ago I
was in an international
development field
and was working in Afghanistan
briefly and wanted to do yoga.
And I learned about
Yoga Glow and actually
did a bunch of Dice's
classes in Afghanistan,
where there was barely
any internet connection
and really enhanced my practice.
And so thinking on the
positive side of technology
and how you said there's
a global community,
I would have never had that
without this kind of thing.
So I think it is all
about the balance
and not letting it
take over your life,
but using it to your advantage.
So just some anecdotes.
So you kind of
already-- like Tom,
you were already kind
of talking about this.
But this is a good segue.
If you could, and you can,
what one piece of advice would
you give to audience
members who want
to improve their
overall well-being,
one piece of advice.
And we can start the other
way, just to spice it up.
TOM FREEMAN: Excellent.
So yeah, this is me just
speaking personally.
But definitely taking some
time out of your day to
look after your mind.
I think it starts
with just 10 minutes.
And through Headspace you can
do three-minute meditations.
You can do a
one-minute meditation
if you're really, really busy.
But kind of making a priority
just for sitting there
around doing nothing.
I think, as we're so
busy, we're running around
from meeting to meeting
or getting to work
or stuck in traffic or
whatever that is, just
blocking out that 10 minutes
just to have time for yourself,
I think.
And then the benefits, and
speaking personally again here,
but the benefits it can have
on so many areas of your life.
So in terms of your relationship
with stress or anxiety,
there's no way I would have
been up here on a panel
two or three years ago.
I would have probably
been in the kitchen eating
loads of food.
But anyway, and I'm still
there but that relationship
with how you relate
to everyday things,
whether it's stress,
anxiety, sports, eating,
all those things.
I think, if it starts with
just taking time for yourself
personally, that's kind of, I
think, a huge benefit in that.
So just blocking out
10 minutes in your day
in the morning maybe
after you get up,
before brush your teeth.
Personally, also, anchoring
it to like an everyday thing.
Another common
question we get is,
I don't have the
time to meditate.
I don't have 10
minutes in my day.
And it can sound--
some people it's
like, wh 10 minutes
doesn't sound very much.
But when you're busy, it is.
But finding that time to
anchor it into your days,
maybe after you
brush your teeth.
Hopefully everyone brushes
their teeth every day.
If they don't, that's cool.
But, yeah, anchoring it to
something you do every day,
and then you say, OK,
after I brush my teeth,
I'm going to sit for 10
minutes before I go to work,
before I jump in the car.
And then it's done for the day.
And that can help you
set up your whole day
in a different way.
And for some people,
it's in the evening.
For some people, it's
after lunch at work,
just finding a room
at work to do that in.
Whatever works for you,
whatever time works for you,
I think just finding that
time, somewhere that's quiet,
somewhere that's
private, and just, yeah,
finding 10 minutes for yourself
I think is a good start.
JEFFREY EGLER: Thanks for that.
It's hard to come up
with something that's
more important than that.
My off-the-cuff
doctor answer is food.
Food matters.
But I think because
that's sort of probably
more obvious to some of
the people in the room,
I would say that maybe a more
unique answer to me would be--
so I was talking a few
minutes ago about technology
and how all of us
here can actually
have a doctor in their home.
But I think many of
us would probably
think twice about having
a doctor in their home.
Do I really want a doctor
on my screens in my home
or at my place of work?
And that's what we're
trying to at Parsley
is really change
the relationship
of people with a doctor and
change what a doctor means.
I don't want to be somebody
that comes to me when they're
sick looking for a medication.
I want to have relationships
with younger people,
that we start to
talk about health.
And what Tom was saying
before about some of us
feel like we don't have 10
minutes in a day to meditate.
And I would say if
that's your mentality,
you've probably got a lot
bigger problems than that.
And when what I mean
by that is you probably
have a lifestyle that's not
going to really work out so
well for you in the long term.
And so having somebody that you
trust, whether it's a physician
or a different type
of provider that
can help you look
objectively at your life
at an early stage when you think
things are going well and maybe
start to accumulate some data--
I agree with Andy
that we don't want
to necessarily don't
need to always obsess
about minor pieces of data.
But they can be helpful
to kind of give us
a reflection if we are really
as healthy as we think we are
and to rethink some
of our health habits.
KIM WHITMAN: Yeah,
all in agreement.
And I have to say, though, the
one thing that you should do
is yoga.
Obviously.
MELISSA MONAHAN: So this
was sponsored by Yoglers.
gPause.
KIM WHITMAN: No.
Well, and I only say that
because I now preach meditation
as my number one thing.
But I would never have
gotten there without yoga.
It actually took me eight
years of yoga practice,
consistent practice,
and a yoga show
that I happened to be running
as well to actually commit
to a meditation practice.
And I think the only
reason was that yoga
is a moving meditation.
So as a monkey-minded
person that can't sit still,
and I like to ski and I'm always
sore from doing something,
I needed that segue
into meditation
with a physical practice.
And actually, yoga was
really designed just
to prepare your body to sit
for hours in meditation.
And so it truly is the
precursor to meditation.
So if you can do both,
then that's the way to go.
And one more thing I want
to say about meditation
is I have started
giving-- be gentle
to yourself is the other
piece of advice, I guess,
that I have for everyone.
And you don't have
to be so hard core
and like-- so I've allowed
myself to do the morning
meditation in Savasana in
my bed with a little pillow
over my eyes.
And if I fall back
asleep, it's OK
because I needed
that extra sleep.
But I do my 20 minutes every
morning from my pillow,
and that's fine.
I don't have to be a monk.
So start with that.
And then if you can
work it in, instead
of going for the second cup
of coffee in the afternoon
when you start to drag, go and
do your second 20 minute or 10
or whatever is--
3.
But, yeah, yoga
leads to meditation,
which is the ultimate.
And be nice to yourself.
Those are three
pieces of advice.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: I
mean, I'm basically
going to be saying
the same thing,
I think, that everybody said
because they're all honest ways
to really help yourself,
especially if you're, I think,
working with a tech company.
But definitely just
to add on, I think
being able to put down
your technology is huge,
and it's so hard.
I know in my household
specifically,
I have a four-year-old.
Watching someone that young be
so attracted to technology so
early on, having to limit
his use and even TV use,
it's pretty amazing.
It's made him much more--
when I used to give
him more technology,
he honestly was so quick at--
instant gratification became
more and more like apparent.
He would want to change
things so quickly, so often.
And once I started to get
him off of technology more
and weaned him off
of it, his ability
actually pay
attention to one thing
became a whole lot better.
And that's just a
four-year-old, who is really,
I think, in the more present
moment than many of us
are as adults.
So as adults, if all you
ever do is sit at a computer
and you're on your phone
and you're constantly
having to stay connected with
your business, your emails
and all that, I think although
it may seem difficult,
and you're like, well,
I run my life this way,
taking 30 minutes--
or if you have
a rule of like
stepping into your home
and literally dropping it
into a bucket for an hour
or something.
Things like that will definitely
help you out in the long run
up here, for sure.
I think on the more, I think,
meditation, the physical realm,
yoga asana and all
of that, with yoga,
there's so many
different realms.
There's so many different limbs
or legs to it, you could say.
And for most of us, we're
a highly physical culture
or being, really, right?
So we really relate to our
bodies and our physical self.
The more we exercise
and move, typically
the better we feel up top.
But you start to
realize that there
are so many other elements
that you can work on.
And what it all comes
down to, I think,
personally, is you're
just always working
on self-improvement,
self-betterment,
self-awareness, and
realizing what things
make you feel better, also
what things make you tick, what
things sends you off
the deep end, how
you react to certain situations,
people, things like that.
The more you start to ask
those kinds of questions
about yourself and not
necessarily be attached
to a good or bad
outlook on yourself,
I think the better you're
going to be in the long run.
It'll make you a
healthier person,
especially if you're
around something
as amazing as technology
that you guys are
using all the time.
Yeah.
ANDY PETRANEK: So I
love this question
because I've been
asked that a lot.
And in developing the
Whole Life Challenge,
I had thought about
it a lot because we
have a much broader context.
We have seven daily
habits, as opposed to--
and they're all important.
All these answers
have been fantastic.
And they're all important.
So the question then is,
well, where do I start?
And where do I go?
And what I always tell people
is there are two things.
The best way to start is to
walk through the door you're
willing to walk through.
If somebody came into my gym and
all they wanted to talk about
was being able to
do 100 push-ups,
I wouldn't start talking to
them about food or meditation,
because that's not
the door that they're
willing to walk through.
So if you are considering
getting started down the health
path, if you want to go
down the meditation route,
that's the route
you should take.
And that route, kind of
like what you were saying,
is that leads to other things.
Yoga leads to meditation
and might lead to push-ups.
You know, when you
do enough Chaturangas
and fall on your
face, you might need
to strengthen your upper body.
But take the path that
you're willing to go through
and use that as you're keystone.
Like we deal with habits a lot
in the Whole Life Challenge.
So use that as your
keystone habit.
And if you're
willing to address,
say, sleep in your life, great.
If you improve your sleep
by 20 minutes a night or you
improve the quality or the
lack of light in your bedroom,
fantastic.
And you start feeling
a little bit better,
than maybe you'll have a little
bit more energy with which
to deal with some of
the stress that you're
feeling with your spouse.
And maybe when you start
dealing with the stress
that you're feeling
with your spouse
a little bit better, maybe
that leads to, oh, man,
now I've got the
energy to work out,
and I'm going to actually get
up in the morning and work out.
So it's kind of like--
it's like a snowball effect.
And it's a more meta answer.
I don't have an answer for you.
You've got to be willing to
find the thing and the door
that you're willing to
walk through and then
walk through it,
MELISSA MONAHAN: These
are all awesome answers,
I hope y'all are taking note.
That's going to be on video.
I realized I never introduced
myself at the beginning.
I'm Melissa Monahan.
I'm a recruiter here and
our yogler representative,
and this talk is for
yogler, gPause, [INAUDIBLE]..
So I realize you might be like--
actually, I know half the room,
but it's fine.
KIM WHITMAN: And you
also teach the yoga here.
MELISSA MONAHAN: I also
teach yoga every Friday,
so check it out.
KIM WHITMAN: Plug that.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Plug it.
So one last question, and then
we have a couple of minutes
for audience questions,
if y'all have any.
So please take advantage
of these experts.
Back to the tech topic, as you
know, Google's a tech company.
And there's lots
of us out there.
So what would you like
to see tech companies,
like Google or others, do or
invent to further innovate
within the wellness space?
So this could be a product, a
campaign, advocacy, anything
that you think?
When we have these types
of resources and platform,
is there anything that you
would hope to see us do?
TOM FREEMAN: Yeah,
I think, broadly,
just thinking about diversity
and getting out there
to as many people as
we can and just helping
all different communities,
engaging with tech,
and hopefully finding
some use for it.
I think practically,
I don't know.
I sometimes do think about this.
Because when you're
bombarded by so much,
whether it's 1,000
tabs in your browser
or it's apps shouting
at you, this idea
of how can devices become
smarter to like switch off.
Is there like an
out-of-office mode?
Your phone goes on.
And then you put it
for x-hours a day.
And your phone is just,
like, no one can reach you.
And then your phone sends in
my office saying, actually,
Tom is offline for two hours.
He'll get back to
you at lunchtime.
But how can our devices, how
can software become smarter,
whether it's--
gosh, I should probably sign
an NDA actually for this idea.
But like even a browser,
can a browser shut down?
Or does your browser
reminds you every half hour
to take a minute
to do something,
whether it's a minute of
meditation or something
like that, just something
that's popping up.
I think the pop-up thing
can be really annoying.
At the same time,
we're reminded to break
you're habits in a day.
It's also quite interesting.
So I think, yeah, just something
software wise is helping us,
that relationship with
tech in a different way,
reminding us to
disconnect, I think,
rather than just us letting
it be owned and open more tabs
and get more apps
shouting at us.
How can we actually let
our devices kind of control
us for a bit, I think?
MELISSA MONAHAN: I like that.
Cool.
JEFFREY EGLER:
All right, Google.
[LAUGHTER]
I've been waiting
for Google to ask me
this question for a long time.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm excited right now.
All right, Google your mission,
should you choose to accept it
is this.
So this is a very
selfish request.
But it is in the
interest of all patients.
And that is what we have seen
in technology on the physician
side of things in
the past 10 years,
there's been a lot of
incredible developments.
And a lot of them we can
hold in the palm of our hand.
But what I have been
completely underwhelmed with
is the lack of
significant benefit
of electronic medical records.
So over a decade or so,
this was the big boom
in health industry, right?
And it's now a
billion-dollar industry.
There's too many
to count, scores
of electronic medical
records systems.
But what they are
all really lacking
is what we had hoped
for in the first place.
Really, the original
intent is clear
and clinical decision
support systems,
help physicians take all the
data that is available to them
and make better decisions
with their patients,
not for their patients.
And now we're seeing
such an explosion
of even more and more data.
Genetics information
is now available to us.
Information regarding the
microbiome in your gut,
I can go on and on and on
with the different types
of testing that we do in our
more cutting-edge practice.
But the problem is with more
data comes more complexity.
And there is no right
answer for everybody.
What doctors typically
use are guidelines.
This is the historic way
that doctors operate.
And guidelines are basically
based on population medicine,
large studies.
And so we need ways to
integrate all of these things.
The cognitive load for
physicians is too great.
There are too many factors
to help people decide
what are the best
decisions for themselves,
even whether it's diet or how to
sleep or what kind of exercise
to be doing.
So I think that the greatest
revolution in the future moving
forward will be AI
and other technologies
that help doctors take
all this information
and boil it down to the
best recommendations
for individual patients.
So there you go.
I'm available to talk to, too.
[LAUGHTER]
KIM WHITMAN: Yeah,
that was amazing.
Actually, agree
with all of that.
And I'm going to take mine until
way more entertainment lean.
It's not nearly as critical
for human survival.
But I love that.
No, I am very-- as
Yoga Today has always
been sort of in the forefront
of like production quality
for bringing the user
into an experience.
We shoot them 4K
in national parks.
And people are like,
is that a green screen?
And like do you realize
how much work that was?
It was not a green screen, OK?
We're in with like flies
buzzing around us and bison.
Anyways, the point
is I want to be
able to use VR to
give people in cities
that aren't in these beautiful
places the same experience.
Because I can't describe to
you what it's like to do a yoga
show in front of the Tetons.
Like to be on the show, you're
just like, what is happening?
It's so amazing.
And people just don't
get enough connection
with the natural world, now
that I'm trying living in city--
I'm trying to live in
LA, and it's different.
And so I want to give
people that access
to the natural world through VR.
I know they're already
doing VR yoga in Korea.
I'm going to go check it out.
Yeah, I know.
It's so cool.
And I think it's more
like animatronic.
And we want it to be like
high-production value,
and then we want
the Google Glass
to be able to just flip from
I'm in the Tetons with them,
or I'm in a studio
with a bunch of people.
And after class be able to
make that connection face
to face with people
instead of, oh, I
see 16 people are in
this class with me.
But I don't see them.
So I am so excited about VR.
And that's when I'm
geeking out on right now.
And that's where I want
Google to come help us out.
Cool.
MELISSA MONAHAN: There's
some engineers in here.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: I think
what I want to say is Google,
keep doing what you're doing.
Just being able to
be up on a panel
like this with other health
professionals and wellness
professionals and being
able to talk about it,
that's already something
that you guys are amazing at.
And it's bringing, I think,
more and more of, I guess,
bigger companies or bigger
conglomerates kind of coming
together and cooperating
with one another,
I think, to just help
other human beings out.
That's all I ask
you guys keep doing.
You guys have so much power in
the world, I mean, literally.
And it's a cheesy line,
but with great power
comes great responsibility.
[LAUGHTER]
And in a sense, doing
what you're doing,
which is trying to
bring ease, technology,
make things better for human
beings around the world.
But I think it starts with the
collaboration and the coming
together.
And that's huge, so you
guys are already doing it.
Just keep doing it.
And realize the impact
that you have on the world.
That's all.
I think that's all I got.
MELISSA MONAHAN: And I think
we could do more collaboration,
because we can do this,
but sometimes we're
competitive with
other tech companies.
And we're not necessarily
always working together to do.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: And I know
it's not one sided on that.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Yeah.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: It
takes two to tango.
MELISSA MONAHAN: But it's good.
I like that.
It's good thinking.
Andy?
ANDY PETRANEK: Have
you guys ever seen
the show "Black Mirror"?
MELISSA MONAHAN: Oh,
I love all of them.
ANDY PETRANEK: Don't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Because my brain goes-- like,
I cannot wait for my car to be
the last car that I ever drive.
I'm so excited about autonomous
vehicles and driving.
I love driving.
It's not that I
don't like driving.
But I want to do it when I
go to a racetrack for fun.
I don't need to
drive around town.
I can't wait to order
up my car, and my car
shows up without a driver and
takes me where I need to go.
And then it never has to park.
It can just be cruising
around, waiting
to pick up the next person.
But "Black Mirror," holy crap.
It just takes it to
the next extreme,
like chips and
being able to delete
your memory and your
people out of your life
and kill people
through technology.
It's just crazy.
So if you haven't watched
it, it's a great show to--
well, maybe it's
not a great show.
[LAUGHTER]
MELISSA MONAHAN: It's
a great show I love it.
ANDY PETRANEK: It's scary.
It's black.
But no, seriously, I
agree 100% with what
Dice said about
being responsible,
like removing consciousness
and removing awareness
from the human, making us
less human through the use
of technology would be a
step in the wrong direction.
And so I think Google
being conscious
of what they're developing
and how they're developing it,
and then what's the-- we always
have to think about rules.
As a professional
athlete, you tend
to win things when
you're either the fastest
or you're the best at
skirting the rules just
inside the barriers
of the rules.
And I think one of the
things with technology
is, well, at least
when we do it,
is we have to think,
well, how are people going
to use this rule
either in their favor
or maybe not in their favor
in order to score points
or in order to get
a better score?
And I think that
is very important
that technology
companies, especially
ones with as much
power as Google,
are aware of and conscious of.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Great.
Those are great--
this is a great panel.
I'm just going to tell you.
So we are at 1:00.
Does anyone have questions?
We have the really awesome--
all right, I just want
to throw it to you.
So let's see what
this is all about.
DICE IIDA-KLEIN: What is it?
MELISSA MONAHAN:
It's a microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
Let's see, so I immediately
forgot my question
once I was put on the spot.
[LAUGHTER]
So, yeah, there is kind of
this paradox of wellness
and technology being
1,000 years old,
and then also it seems like
it's really advancing really
quickly right now.
And so there's a lot
of experimentation
being done with both.
And so with that
we get fads, which
are initially a good idea, but
they might not have longevity.
What are some fads
that you can't
wait to see go away forever, be
they socially or different apps
or products in your
respective fields?
And then to be less cynical,
what are some things that you
wish you saw more of
or perhaps directions
for your respective
fields in the near term?
ANDY PETRANEK: I can
answer that first one.
I don't think
they'll ever go away.
But they need to go away is
this idea that a diet can
solve your problems.
There's any one diet
that's the right diet
and that you can do it in four
months or four weeks or eight
weeks, or like you'll
do it and it'll be over
and you'll achieve what
you want to achieve,
and then you can get
on with your life.
It's just not true.
And it never will be true.
And it's like a
layer of an onion.
You keep peeling it, peeling
it, and you keep working at it
and keep working at it.
And it's a lifelong
journey that you're on.
I'd love to see diets
just die a quick death.
I don't remember your
second question, so.
JEFFREY EGLER: I'll piggyback
on that, if you don't mind.
And I can pick on a couple
of fads, if you like.
But one of the trends that
I would like to see go away
is just what Andy
was referring to is
the overnight fixes, the magic
bullets, the eight-minute abs.
So as an example, Parsley,
we do year-long memberships.
And we have a membership
model because we
don't believe that people get
healthy with one magic visit
to a super smart doctor.
We think that it's a process.
Again, a cheesy line, but
it's a journey, not an event.
And so that's what
we're trying to do
is that people get on the
trolley with this thing
that we're going to develop.
And like you said
also before, we're
going to pick that one door that
you're willing to walk through.
And so many people were just
like, well, I want to do this.
Then I want to do this.
I want to get the most
out of my first 30 days.
You will get the most
out of your first 30 days
when you are successful at the
most important thing that's
standing right in front of you.
I always tell people
that if I give you
one thing to do this month,
you have an 85% or so chance
of successfully doing that.
But if I give you just
two, it drops to below 50%.
And if I give you three, it's
down less than 15% as well.
So putting one foot in
front of the other, I think,
is the best way to go.
And then the thing I'd like to
see us get rid of is gluten.
I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
But I do bring up
gluten-free diets
as an example of further
educating ourselves,
because what I have seen
with gluten is it's a fad.
It's a real thing.
I mean people have
gluten sensitivities.
But in the science that
we're using and incorporating
is that not everybody
is going to benefit
from a gluten-free diet.
There is a certain percentage
of people that will.
And what we've also
learned now is that there's
what we've suspected all
along, as physicians,
is that it might be
gluten, but it's probably
some other things in wheat.
And now we can test
for those things too.
So I bring it up
as sort of a joke.
And certainly it's a real thing.
But it's not just that.
And there's other
things that we need
to be informing people about.
KIM WHITMAN: And I'd like to
answer the second question.
One thing that I think
is not going away,
and maybe I'm just
an eternal optimist,
but I think it's mindfulness.
I think as we dive
deeper into AI and tech,
and as our society leans
harder on machine learning
and all of this, I think we're
A, freeing up our time so
that we can act more
productively, I hope,
is what's happening.
And that's where we're
going to be moving
more towards the mindfulness
space and yoga and health
and wellness and connection,
human connection.
And I think people need it more
and more as we are surrounded
in like a media cloud.
We need to be able to separate.
And people are recognizing that.
And I feel really optimistic.
I know you look at the
younger generation,
and you're like, how
is that possible?
But I think there's going to be
a tipping point with everybody.
And I'm optimistic that
that's going to stick around.
I hope.
MELISSA MONAHAN: Great.
Any other questions?
Toss that mic back there.
I know we're over time,
but these are really
all great questions.
AUDIENCE: Test.
Test.
So I think it's wonderful that
at a technology and fitness
convention plays
the devil's advocate
and says turn your phone
off and find yourself.
And I love that.
And I think all of you
are wonderful and have
made the most insightful,
important recommendations
to anyone who is
either at a high level
or starting and entering
a door and where to go.
I think in the exact
opposite direction, however,
I would love to have
all six of you with me
at all times in my
phone constantly
monitoring me and maybe
bickering among yourselves.
Be like, nah, nah, nah,
not CrossFit today.
He needs a little headstand
and breathe, and you know what?
Eat this.
But I know you ate
gluten yesterday.
You're processing it, you know?
So like when is that toy coming?
[LAUGHTER]
KIM WHITMAN: There's a
price tag for everything.
We're willling.
ANDY PETRANEK: That's super
smart, super smart AI.
I don't know about that.
AUDIENCE: It's not, though.
It's an intuition.
And you are all very
intuitive about your clients
and about having a
relationship in a way
that AI will never have.
You can see it, I'm tired.
You can see it, you need this.
Or you can see
it, you know what?
Just breathe.
Just think for a minute.
And I think that is
where we're going.
And that's all.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY EGLER: I
absolutely agree.
And you're right.
There are so many--
and that's sort
of what I was speaking to
before, too, is that there are
so many individual technologies
out there, like Headspace,
for example, that
are just wonderful,
like the yoga businesses
that we have here.
But there's a lack of bringing
those things together.
And I think that
that is very cultural
because everybody is wanting
their business to move forward.
But I do think that
the salvation of us
all will be the best
technologies working together.
And so I, like you, look forward
to those kind of collaborations
and those products.
AUDIENCE: Like Spotify
eventually took everything,
gave it to you.
MELISSA MONAHAN: I like that.
Anything else?
JEFFREY EGLER: The other thing--
I'm sorry.
MELISSA MONAHAN:
Yeah, oh, please.
JEFFREY EGLER: I don't mean
to just keep jumping in.
But it just reminds me.
The other thing that, and
this is sort of the model
that we have created and are
trying to expand is that A,
there needs to be
a paradigm shift.
There's a great book out there.
It's called "The Patient
Will See You Now."
And it's written about
how the patient needs
to be the center, rather than
the old paternalistic doctor
telling the patient
what to do, right?
We're consultants.
But we also work
with health coaches
who are part of our team.
And I think ultimately
the best team
to work with a
member or a patient
in the future would be a
fitness person, a meditation
person, somebody that's
doing the psychology,
somebody that's making sure
that they are doing safe yoga
practices, interdisciplinary
teams, which
is not a novel idea.
But it's not the norm.
And I think it's going to need
to be before we can really
make progress.
ANDY PETRANEK: It's
something you just said.
I think that one of the
things we try to teach
is the patient
being responsible.
The patient's the
CEO of the company.
The CEO has to
make the decisions.
The CEO doesn't pass the buck
to the board or to the chief.
You might have a chief doctor.
You might have a chief trainer
and a therapist and a yoga
instructor.
But you make the decisions.
And I think very often
we look to the experts
as if they know more than we do.
And people forget that--
or maybe they never knew--
that their intuition
could perhaps
be more powerful than
even every book that
was ever written by any
Harvard expert or anybody else.
They have to be responsible
for making that decision.
And sometimes it's
the exact opposite
of what everybody
else is saying.
But if it's in
alignment for them,
that's the best answer, so.
KIM WHITMAN: Yeah,
and then in yoga,
you are your greatest teacher.
So I think, yeah, listening
to all the experts,
absorbing the information, but
being authentic to yourself
and your gut is ultimately,
yeah, the best guide.
MELISSA MONAHAN: I
think you've clued
into this is a great
assortment of people,
which was my thinking.
So what we'll do is once we've
the video, we'll send it out
so you have it.
And then we'll include links to
all of their various companies
and social media
and all of that,
but only check it once a day,
so that you have the access
and can even reach out and
ask additional questions.
Anybody else have anything you
want to ask of these folks?
Any parting words that
y'all want to share,
pass the wisdom
you've already shared?
Well, let's give them a hand.
They're really amazing.
[APPLAUSE]